has spent nearly half of her life at
this Israeli checkpoint
born in Annapolis Hospital late on
Monday her parents are trying to bring
her home to kalkilia City a trip that
often takes around 40 minutes but it's
been hours due to an Israeli blockade
imposed on Nablus more than a week ago
the baby has a little difficulty
breathing so we want to take her to an
incubator Aline is one of hundreds
trying to leave Nablus through this
checkpoint which is the only way out
I've been waiting for more than one and
a half hours I won't make any profit gas
is expensive and I'm wasting it on the
roads
Israel says The Siege aims to prevent
the growing number of gun attacks the
Israeli Army told Al Jazeera more than
170 have been carried out so far this
year
an armed group in nablis called the
Lion's Den has claimed responsibility
for several attacks in recent weeks an
Israeli soldier was killed in one drive
by shooting last week
the Israeli policy of collective
punishment is not new for decades Israel
has been demolishing Palestinian homes
blocking roads and imposing measures
against whole communities and
neighborhoods Palestinians say they're
being killed detained and their lives
are getting more difficult all under the
pretext of security Israeli officials
believe the blockade will put pressure
on Palestinians to abandon arms and
deter them from carrying out attacks
while the Palestinian Authority has
succeeded in recruiting some fighters to
its ranks analysts say only a political
solution will end the need for armed
groups
General dissatisfaction with the
Palestinian Authority has led to many
people supporting them despite the
growing Israeli restrictions uh it's a
reaction that people would give
legitimacy and give support to any group
to any
person to any faction if you want that
may come out and show that resilience
that we missed for so so many many many
many years those negotiations and
Promises of Independence and statehood
have been going on for decades and that
means baby Ellen and her fellow
Palestinians could be looking at a
lifetime of waiting
the occupied West Bank